hey everyone welcome to this next
episode of your daily equation today I'm
going to focus upon an equation that
captures the notion of the relativity of
simultaneity a mouthful right what does
that mean it means that two individuals
that are moving relative to one another
will not agree on what things happen at
the same moment of time they will not
agree on what events what things happen
simultaneously and again it'll come out
again from this notion of the constant
nature of the speed of light an idea
that is so incredibly fruitful at least
in the mind of an Albert Einstein okay
and then after I explain the idea in in
animation form and visuals and to give
you some intuition for the ia well
intuition is probably too strong a word
actually if you think about it many
people have asked me do I have an
intuition for these ideas in relativity
and the answer the most truthful answer
is not really I can follow the chain of
reason I can do the mathematics but do I
have sort of a deep inner intuition in
my bones for these ideas I don't think
that I really do so I don't know if I
can get you to that point but at least I
want to show you the chain of reasoning
so at least you can explain it to
yourself in your own mind for why it is
that these weird implications are true
okay
so to give you that level of
understanding I'm going to begin with a
little story a story I first wrote down
in in my book the elegant universe so
some of you may be familiar with the
story but it goes like this there are
two nations that have long been at war
they are called forward land and
backward land and and that's not a value
judgment by any means as you see it
comes right out of the scenario that
I'll be describing now the two nations
finally have come to a peace treaty but
neither
from the two countries wants to sign the
treaty before the other presidents they
need some scheme that will ensure that
they each sign the treaty simultaneously
so they consult with the United Nations
secretary-general and they come up with
the following plan the two presidents
are going to sit at opposite how do I
orient my hands so they look like ah
there you go you're gonna sit at
opposite ends it's harder than you think
opposite ends it's like I got you know
jazz hands here
opposite ends of a long trade right and
in between them there's going to be a
light bulb and the idea is that the bulb
will initially be in the off position
and then the Secretary General will turn
on the bulb sending light heading left
and right and since the speed of light
is constant isn't affected by the
direction in which it moves and since
each president is equidistant from the
bulb the travel time to each president's
eyeball will be the same when they see
the light each president picks up the
pen signs the treaty and that should be
the means of ensuring that they sign
simultaneously now one little additional
detail that the secretary-general puts
into the scenario a crucial one as we
will see the secretary-general says hey
when you sign the treaty why don't you
let the inhabitants of the two nations
that live on opposite sides of a
railroad track why don't you let them
watch the signing ceremony by doing it
on a train that goes right along that
track and both presidents say sure yeah
why not let's do it on a train so that
everybody can witness this historic
event okay so now let's take a look at a
little animation that will show you what
happens and we'll begin with the
perspective of those on the train the
two presidents and their respective
entourage 'as if that's the right plural
of entourage there's the two presidents
president of forward land facing forward
backward land is facing backward that's
where the names come from the bulb was
in the off position and then we turn on
the bulb and when we do so the light
streaks left
and right heading toward each of the
presidents again same distance same
speed of light so it hits them at the
same moment they pick up their pens they
sign the treaty and everybody is so
thrilled with the outcome but then
surprisingly shockingly unexpectedly all
of these folks on the train get word
that riots have broken out you can see
it here on the platform because the
inhabitants of the two nations do not
agree that the presidents signed at the
same moment in fact they claim that the
president of forward land signed first
and the president of backward land
signed a second let me show you why they
come to this conclusion let's rerun the
scenario but now not from the
perspective of those on the train but
from those on the platform here's what
they see the light goes off and the
president of forward land is running
toward the light so it hits his eye
first president of backward land is
running away so it hits his eye second
let me show you this a little bit more
slowly again speed of light is constant
it's just that the president of forward
land is heading toward the light so look
the light doesn't have to travel as far
to reach his eye boom hits at first
president backward land boom hits him
second because he's running away from
the light light has to travel farther to
reach his eye again this has nothing to
do with the speed of light changing it
has everything to do the speed of light
being constant it is just that the
president of forward land is making it
easier for the light to reach his eye by
heading toward the light light doesn't
have to travel as far the president
forward line has made up some of the
distance by heading toward the light
president of backlund is making it more
difficult for the light to reach his eye
by racing away on the train from that
beam of light light has to travel
farther so in other words we have two
perspectives that I can summarize right
here on the Left the perspective of
those on the train light goes off heads
in both directions equidistant hits both
eyes at the same moment simultaneously
perspective of those on the platform
president before Lent is heading toward
the light therefore it hits his eye
first light doesn't have to travel as
far and you see that the ball of light
is still in transit to reach the
president a backward land according to
those in the platform because the
president tobacco man is running away
from the light light has to travel
farther therefore to reach his eye what
do we make of this the question of
course is who is right those on the
train on the Left perspective those on
the platform the right perspective and
the answer is I suspect many of you no
doubt would guess or know or thought
through they are both right it is not
that one perspective is right and the
other is wrong both perspectives are
right even though they come to the
shocking conclusion that according to
those on the train the events of the two
presidents seeing the light and signing
the treaty are simultaneous well
according to those on the platform those
events are not simultaneous and in a
sense on I'm actually tempted to just
stop our discussion right here because
that is such a deep insight into the
nature of time again before Einstein the
view was that there is a universal
notion of what happens at a given moment
a universal notion of what things happen
simultaneously but Einstein showed that
the constant nature of the speed of
light which is vital to this story
because the light is having to travel
different distances according to those
on the platform at the same speed and
therefore it doesn't complete its
journey simultaneously according to
those on the platform those two events
are not simultaneous and you know just
referring back to the elegant universe I
remember I said writing as a young man
you know whatever it was more than 20
years ago that if you took one thing
away from the
this scenario of the treaty signing
ceremony and how it allows you to come
to the conclusion that simultaneity is
in the eye of the beholder in the eye of
the observer if you took that away I'd
be satisfied if that in fact was the
only point you took away I feel the same
here if in this whole series the one
thing that sticks is the relativity of
simultaneity and this little story that
allows you to think through why it's
true I will feel like this whole series
has served its purpose but I'm not going
to stop here this is called your daily
equation for a reason which is I want to
now just spend a couple of minutes won't
take long to derive mathematically the
time discrepancy according to those on
the platform between these two events
between the president of forward land
signing the treaty and the president a
backward land signing the treaty and
that is not hard to do we're going to
get a formula that expresses that time
difference in terms of the speed of the
train that's vital the train wasn't
moving everybody would agree on what
things happen at the same moment you
need observers in relative motion and
also as we'll see what comes into the
formula is the distance between the two
presidents and that has an interesting
implication which I will finish up with
now to get there let me use my iPad here
and let me try to bring it up on the
screen good all right so now you and I
we can now work this out together how to
do that all right let me just draw a
little picture so imagine that I have my
train I'm not going to really draw a
train but schematically and I've got the
president of forward land facing forward
backward land facing back and in between
right we have our little light bulb and
I don't know the little light bulb gives
off you know some light that will stream
both left and right toward each of the
two presidents and we want to work out
the time difference between it hitting
those two presidents so to do that
first work out the amount of time that
it takes that beam of light to reach the
president from backward land how do we
do that well bear in mind that once the
light is emitted it streams toward the
president of backward land so certainly
it has to cover the distance between the
bulb to the president so let's give that
a name let's say that the entire
distance between the two presidents
let's call that equal to L and therefore
you've got L over 2 and L over 2 being
the two distances the light needs to
travel but because the train is moving
while the light is in transit president
to backward land is actually going to
move a little bit toward the right while
the light is in transit how far will the
president to backward land move well if
the speed of the train is V and it takes
a time t be for the light to reach the
president then the distance that it will
have to travel is half the length of the
Train plus V times TB so it's got to
cover half the length of the train it's
also got to cover at the distance that
the president of backward land raced
away while the light was flying toward
him and therefore it must be the case
that C times TB that is the total
distance that the light travels before
it hits the president of bakwin land in
the eye must be L over 2 plus V times TB
and that allows us to solve for T V then
we can just write T B times C minus V
equals L over 2 and therefore TB is
equal to L over 2 times C minus V okay
now let's do the same calculation for
the amount of time from the perspective
of those on the platform for the light
to reach the president of forward land
the only difference here
is that the distance that the light
needs to travel is now L over 2 minus
the distance that the president of
forward land travels while the light is
in transit because forward land
president of Portland is going toward
the light makes it easier decreases the
distance that the light needs to travel
and well how far does the train travel
while the light is in transit V times TF
and again just as above we can solve
that TF now it's C + V only differences
that sign L over 2 and therefore TF is
equal to L divided by 2 times C + V all
right so we have the the 2 times TB over
here and TF over here and to get the
discrepancy between those two events
that is the lack of simultaneity of
those two events we just can subtract
those let's do t be minus TF what do we
get so we get L over 2 times 1 over 2
times C minus V minus 1 whoops already
have a 2 there I mean don't want to
double it up 1 over C minus V times 1
over C + V and that gives us then L over
2 and I'm going to combine those by
putting them over the same denominator C
squared minus V squared how do I get
that well I'm going to multiply the left
term by C + V and you see plus B times C
minus V get C squared minus V squared so
it's C + V from the first term - and I
have to multiply above and below
denominator numerator by C minus V on
the right and now we can just get L over
2 times upstairs - V divided by C
squared minus V squared so our formula
then is L V divided by C squared minus V
squared and that's it that's the formula
that we are looking for this L is the L
measured by
on the platform so you don't have to
worry about length contraction per se
it's built into the very definition of L
and the formula is quite nice though
there's another way I can write it let
me also write this as L times V over C
divided by C times 1 minus V over C
squared all I did was pull some seeds on
the top and the bottom to write it in
that form and writing it that way is
particularly nice because V over C in
everyday life is a small number and
therefore this time difference this is
the time difference between the two
events is minuscule and that's why in
everyday life we are not aware of the
relativity of simultaneity but if the
over C is large then that relativity of
simultaneity that time difference will
grow larger and larger but I want to
finish up by just noting one other
curious fact that's kind of fun to bear
in mind because there's this factor of L
that comes into the time difference
formula you can also make this
expression large not only by making V
approach C that's sort of the usual
thing in relativity you say hey how can
you make the effects bigger you got to
go to higher and higher speed you can
also make it large by letting L whoops
let me get rid of that guy over here
that's making this guy L goes big big
separation between the two events of
interest and so if you imagine that even
if you have slow speeds V over C is a
small number but two observers are very
far apart maybe on you know opposite
sides of the universe there's some
subtleties that even come into talking
about the notion of time over such large
distance scales but put that to the side
on very very large distances even small
velocities can you
of significant discrepancies in what
observers claim to happen at the same
moment so sort of a second lever arm for
making the effects of relativity larger
and larger okay that's the equation that
I wanted to get to today the equation
that captures the relativity of
simultaneity and I think next time I'll
pick it up probably I keep guessing and
I make the wrong guess as to what I'll
do next I kind of changed my mind every
time I sit down to do this but I think
I'm going to focus upon relativistic
mass for at least some time soon I'll do
relativistic mass maybe it will be the
next episode in any event that's it for
today that is your daily equation
looking forward to seeing you next time
take care